violets night it is the end of the week
it is Friday hard to believe but we also
have notable quotables only a monster
does this
last night President Trump said the FBI
rage raid was a disgrace situation it's
a total which I will see what happened
mr. president will you fire the Attorney
General
what about ordering the fire sometimes
as Coach Saban likes to say you flat-out
made them quit they quit
we're doing that to a lot of people too
I'd like to think I have done my part my
little part in history to set us in a
better course the guy takes a shot at
you you take shoot two shots back at him
understand this the Trump
trillion-dollar deficit it's here for
the life of his presidency may that be
short
what a joke is he gonna wear a suit and
tie and clean white shirt there's some
impurities in the Facebook punch bowl
Facebook has initially shut down the
chick-fil-a Appreciation Day page just
for my sister on this thing national
sibling day though he'll dispute this I
can beat my son in cornhole every day
[Laughter]
[Applause]
well there you go notable quotables that
was just one week